au premier abord c'est un grand espace
blanc mais sur chaque mur de la tanière
de houdan se trouvent plusieurs estampes
je vous présente catherine gillet c'est
du pur burin c'est à dire qu'elle
employait le même le même du rhin que
durèrent au xvème siècle ça c'est le
l'outillage classique c'est le classique
c'est des petits traits on creuse le
cuir avec un petit but rhin ça c'est la
gravure sur bois de raul vie milhas
chaque couleur à une planche et son tir
est successivement pour pour atteindre
ce ses effets colorés de matière
c'est très très proche de la peinture
finalement beaucoup plus proche de la
peinture peu noir et blanc cette
exposition de gravures intitulé morsures
et autres empreintes en accès libre
jusqu'au 26 juin est le fruit du travail
de 18 artistes
on voulait montrer cette diversité et
cette capacité que les graveurs ou
de rebondir c'est à dire qu'il ne
s'enferme pas dans des techniques fondée
en 1974 l'association regards parole
s'attelle à présenter une demi douzaine
d'expositions par an dans cet espace au
coeur de houdan faut savoir que depuis
12 ans nous sommes entièrement hébergée
par l'abbé par la mairie ce qu'il y a un
énorme cadeau donc pour remercier le
maire de cette action nous avons décidé
d'une façon commune enfin tous ensemble
de d'offrir à la commune une oeuvre
chacun d'entre nous offrir à une oeuvre
un grand projet de remerciements prévue
au mois de décembre pour les 28 artistes
du collectif dont l'exposition
actuellement en place et la dernière de
la saison